kanye west and irina shaikh may have
gotten people talking after they were
spotted spending time together in france
last month
but now a source tells et the
relationship was never serious
i mean it was just fun to just do
something for my heart
the two of them have always just been
having fun together
they're both doing their own thing and
down to have a good time without any
strings attached
back in june the two were spotted
spending one-on-one time together while
on vacation
staying at a luxury hotel in provence
france
at the time a source told et that kanye
and arena have quote
casually been seeing each other and have
been friendly for a long time
adding kanye loves having someone in the
fashion world
as that's a big part of his life and
irina enjoys kanye's passion for it the
two have kept things on the dl for a
while
as they are both very private it's
extremely important to me
a second source at the time noted that
the rapper has always thought the model
was
extremely beautiful and cool now that
they are both single at the same time
kanye has been trying to woo arena and
impress her
they're both having a good time together
and kanye really likes that arena is
low-key and private
man
irina previously appeared in kanye's
2010 music video for power
and walked in his yeezy fashion show in
2012.
kanye also name dropped the 35 year old
in his 2010 song
christian dior denim flower
of course kanye's budding romance with
arena comes amid his highly publicized
divorce from kim kardashian
the 40 year old reality star filed for
divorce from the yeezy founder in
february
after six years of marriage they share
four children together
eight-year-old north five-year-old saint
three-year-old chicago
and two-year-old psalm at the end of the
day life is about being happy
meanwhile irina has been co-parenting
her four-year-old daughter leah with
her ex bradley cooper back in march she
opened up about it to l magazine saying
quote
i never understood the term co-parenting
when i'm with my daughter i'm 100
a mother and when she's with her dad
he's 100
her dad co-parenting is parenting but
back to kim
a source previously told et that the
keeping up with the kardashians star
wants nothing but the best for her ex
and adds kim is cool with kanye moving
on
kim is happy for kanye and arena at the
end of the day
kim just wants kanye to be happy she
knows how incredible of a man he is
their relationship just ran its course
and he deserves to be with someone who
makes him happy
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
and the two appear to be on good terms a
source previously told et that the
grammy winner helped kim with the
rebranding of her beauty line
kkw beauty which includes a fresh update
with new formulas
packaging and a revamped website and the
source clarifies that although kim and
kanye have split
the beauty mogul will not be dropping
the w from the name
kkw beauty and in june kim shared
this family shot on instagram for
kanye's 44th birthday
writing in part quote love you for life
you